Here is a perfect example of this issue.
Notice that there are bust
darts in this knit top.
But can you see that there are
wrinkles at the arm hole?
The bust isn't the issue.
The problem actually is
in the shoulder area.
Here's another example.
Esmeralda, the mannequin,
isn't particularly large busted,
but this blue knit is still showing
wrinkles in the problem area.
Use a piece of cardboard with a 90-degree
angle cut out to determine
your shoulder slope.
Now, adding a dart won't help this issue.
There are still wrinkles.
But as I pinch out the shoulder,
can you see how I'm removing some
of the extra fabric in that area
and eliminating the wrinkles?
As we mentioned in the previous flipbook
pages, you just can't
add shoulder shaping.
You have to consider the depth of the arm
hole and its relationship
with the sleeves.
So if your knitting pattern doesn't
already have shaped shoulders,
below are some ideas for adding them
correctly with whatever
charting method you use.